je pense que cette gifle beaucoup de à
l'époque de gilet jaune ou un peu après
ou même
beaucoup de mouvements qui ont eu lieu
beaucoup de gens qui ne se situent pas
probablement cet auteur se situe en tout
cas c'est du côté de l'extrême droite
mais je pense que beaucoup de gens
d'extrême gauche aurait bien aimé
des baffes aussi au président macron et
voilà le texte ça ne s'est pas produit
et ceci dit il ya toujours si on veut
rester nuancé sur la faire et il se fait
que quand même la présidence macron
remue beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
vieilles traditions deviez hiérarchie en
france et que ça ça ça suscite c'est pas
simplement on a souvent dit que c'est la
colère des plus défavorisés et qui
souffre des politiques néolibérales mais
il ya énormément de corporations qui
skie qui craignent
on est en tout cas qui résiste et qui se
défendent face à ce type de
bouleversements que je pense qu emmanuel
macron a voulu introduire dans la
structure française
beaucoup de gens auraient voulu me
donner des gifles à même des proches
je pense un certain personnes évincées -
elles ne l'ont pas fait et c'est tombé
sur quelqu'un comme ça qu'on a appelé un
quidam il l'a fait mais là aussi je
pense qu'il faut revenir à ce que pierre
verdy vient de dire c'est contexte il ya
un contexte de colère constante et
peut-être peut-être un effet confinement
ont dit que les violences sont un petit
peu trop retenu et qu'elle explose de
façon un peu
à
[Musique]